this video is sponsored by yougov so
recently i found a new way to make some
much needed extra cash on the side and
it's called yougov
it's so simple you just take a survey
about anything from public affairs to
politics to brand products and then you
earn points and then redeem those points
for cash rewards
it's completely free to join and even
offers you extra points when you invite
your friends and family or when you're a
newcomer
if you're a little nervous about
spending money on upcoming games like
metroid dread later this year and beyond
why not answer a few easy questions to
make some quick extra cash and get you
some games
click the link in my description below
to get started today and now on to the
video
bye hi everyone bandit here
e3 has come and e3 has gone that's how
time works
as everyone was able to see the real
show stealer came on the last day of the
conference
when nintendo took the virtual stage but
let's
face it the standard wasn't very high by
the time tuesday came around
nintendo could probably have won the
show with half of the reveals that they
did
on that note though since most of their
big games either didn't get release
dates or aren't slated to release until
2022
breath of the wild 2 one might be
wondering what's left for fans of the
gaming company in 2021
is there hope for using your nintendo
switch console for anything other than a
spare plate when your other dishes are
dirty
i'm here to say yes yes there is here's
my list of the 5 switch games i will
definitely be getting in this last half
of 2021
and remember if you agree with the list
or just feel like being nice
drop a like below to get this video
spread around on youtube and make sure
you're subscribed to stick around for
all the nintendo stuff to come
first up and right around the corner is
the legend of zelda skyward sword hd
most fans of the franchise know this
game was announced by now but surprise
it's coming out in 16 days the upside to
picking this game up is that it's one of
the most criminally underrated and
undersold flagship
zelda games of all time more than worthy
of being enjoyed by the literal millions
of brand new zelda fans that were
introduced to the series after breath of
the wild's release
the downside is that it is a 10 year old
game that nintendo just spruced up a bit
but yet is re-releasing at full price
this is no doubt understandably enough
to discourage some fans from picking up
the hd remaster
however if you haven't gotten to play
this game before and if you're in the
financial situation to be able to afford
it of course i highly recommend picking
it up and enjoying it in crisp
full hd with the motion controls that
everybody loved completely optional this
time around
i know i will be second there's a new
warrior ware coming in september
and fortunately for us warioware get it
together's price tag is only 50 bucks
if you've never gotten to enjoy a
warrior where game before
allow me to summarize how it feels to
play one
warrior ware games are multiplayer
experiences composed of dozens of fun
time-sensitive mini-games that keep you
so involved with its high-speed gameplay
that you won't even be able to
concentrate on the fact that your older
sister is winning
not that that ever happened to me of
course with get it together delivering
over 200 mini-games and being capable of
handling up to four players for those
party nights and costing a bit less than
the other full priced games on this list
i'll definitely be picking this one up
come september 10th
my sister isn't invited third and
possibly the most
impactful of this entire list is metroid
dread releasing on october 8th
guys i don't normally like telling
people what to do with their money but
if
i had to only choose one of these games
out of this entire list
i would choose metroid yes even over
skyward sword hd
this game is a huge deal from every
angle both in regards to the lore of the
franchise and the fact that in regards
to gameplay
it's a new side-scrolling sci-fi action
adventure game i mean what's not to love
the game's price is 60 dollars but i
don't mind this because it's a brand new
beautiful full video game experience
that in my opinion deserves a full
video game price tag metroid games have
also historically not sold super well in
the past at least in comparison to
nintendo's other franchises so i have
high hopes for this one i won't be
sleeping on it and i suggest you don't
either
fourth and also in the month of october
and unfortunately
also for a price of 60 is the next mario
party
super mario party superstars is set to
release on the 29th of october and
what's really special about this one
is that it's not new content it's old
content actually but remade from the
ground up with new visuals sound effects
and controls for the modern nintendo
switch console
if you're like me and you grew up with
the original mario party games on the
nintendo 64 and gamecube or if you've
never played those titles then either
way this should already be pulling out
your heartstrings
especially if you were kind of
disappointed with super mario party as a
lot of fans were
super mario party superstars is going to
have the best maps mini games and even
alternate game modes from the best mario
party games of the past
23 years what's not to like well i'll
tell you what's not to like it's the
full price tag for old content that's
already been made
but at least this one is old content
that's been remade from the ground up
with modern technology in mind so
there's that
whether i'm hosting a game night with
friends not including my sister or
flying solo i'm sure i'll be getting my
money's worth out of this one
last on this list is pokemon brilliant
diamond and shining pearl releasing on
november 19th now this selection of mine
is bound to be a bit more controversial
many fans of the franchise are actually
really frustrated with this remake
i mean just have a look at any comment
section on any video related to these
games
from what i can tell it's mostly because
it's a lackluster remake
visually speaking although there are
more reasons than just that however i'm
gonna let you in on a little secret
about me
my first pokemon game was pokemon go yep
i have somehow stayed out of the pokemon
scene for essentially my entire life
i guess there just wasn't enough room
next to the holy trinity of zelda mario
and halo
so to me this one is less about its
visuals or quality of life improvements
or changes from the original version and
more about just playing diamond and
pearl for the first time
and if that's your story as well chances
are you'll have the same reasoning that
i do
since either of these games would cost
me 60 bucks a piece though i'm only
gonna choose one of them let me know
which one i should pick in the comments
below
and there you have it my list of the
five games i will definitely be picking
up on the nintendo switch before 2022.
did you agree
disagree have other games i should have
included let me know your list in the
comments below and click that like
button on the way down there thank you
very much
if you like discussions and theories
about these popular game franchises
check out all the other cool stuff i do
on the channel and also let me know if
there's a game you'd like me to cover
next
thank you so much for watching and big
thanks of course to my bandit crew
as always i hope you have a wonderful
rest of your day this is mass
antennabanet
signing out and looking forward to
seeing you in the next one
[Music]
you